C yêu cho tốt mở ước kìa mọi người mùi nhà, mù sê được ở sề gó.
Từ kết hơi đẹp mình là sinh viên mình tìm không trở.
Mình tìm viên là thêm.
Chào đơn cái lúc mình đã trường ngô cái trí xe đầu tiên,
ngũ cái lập tợ tìm, mình dọng ngọng ngọng ngọng cái kè.
Chào tất hay tốt hơn.
Chào đơn cái lúc mình có gia đình,
mình cứ vợ ông cần phải mua tất tầm sản,
mình làm chỗ mình thích những viên chẳng mình.
Cái mẹ ngù sèu tốt.
Chợ tốt luôn ở đó khi vọng lòng mọi người sau này mọi kèa,
chào tốt lên sẽ có nhiều sự thách.
Thầy đổi hơn, rất nhiều, sẽ có chú đầy.
Bởi kèo là chắc chẳng là cái số lực vui đường của mình sẽ đại trường nhiều nhiều.
Tính tất cả hiểu mẹ ngọng của con đẹn quan hộn ngọng,
mùi chịu chẳng hẹn thì kéo làm sao từ cái tức bức phá,
có tìm tìm thèo là mùi chịu chế phá là thàn mùi chịu.
Nếu mình có khá năng phát truyện nhận đòi như vải thích chẳng,
mình tất cả các bạn trong tiêm sẽ có thể có khăn này.
Mù sèa sẽ gó.
Cô mừng mừng tất cả mừng sè gó.
Mừng tất cả mùi nhẹ, mù sè đừng có sè góng,
tế hiếp, bọng lòng mùi cũng có thể đạo điều kiện đó,
sẽ cắt bạn trong tiêm mà chất tốt.
Tụi màu, mình như người bởi nó mọi người.
Đi cây.
Đi của mình, đúng sẹp theo,
gửi sẹp, tỏa vọng vọng for customers step, mọi nứt.